[Musique]
les combattants islamistes avaient
réussi à l'orée des milliers de jeunes
occidentaux avec ses vidéos thing
d'hollywood qui présentait le djihad
comme une mission humanitaire
et je lui ai demandé est là les numéros
de téléphone que je vois sur téléphone
c'est pour le lapi de deux séries il m'a
dit oui maman c'est vrai je suis ici
pour défendre les femmes et les enfants
de marché aval à cette saisine noël 2010
tu qu'il était juge a converti le fils
de christian boudreau a été tuées en
syrie en 2014 depuis la femme de calgary
même son propre combat contre la
radicalisation des jeunes
elle a raconté son histoire des
centaines de fois un peu partout dans le
monde mais la douleur du deuil demeure
intacte avec des mamans
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne peut pas
expliquer c'est incroyable la ténacité
qui est là dans nos coeurs elle à
n'importe quoi qui se peut se passer
avec les enfants on veut les aimer
n'importe quoi elle a fondé un organisme
qui regroupe des dizaines de parents qui
ont vu leur fils ou leur fille s'envoler
vers le mirage d'une guerre sainte
plusieurs de ces familles sont déjà dans
la réalité du retour vers des gens qui
sentent menacés du fait qu'ils qu'on
reçoive des réfugiés la pédopsychiatre
dirige une équipe qui accompagne depuis
déjà deux ans de jeunes canadiens qui
reviennent des champs de bataille syrie
ottawa ne donne plus de chiffres mais il
ya un an on affirmer qu'une soixantaine
était déjà revenu quelquefois les gens
l'impression qu'on va être envahi
d'abord ne vois pas du tout un travail
c'est qu'il s'agit de quelques personnes
qui sont déjà arrivés ou qui sont en
train d'arriver
et c'est des gens qui sont extrêmement
surveillé donc dit pas de danger il n'y
a pas de raison d'avoir peur
mais le retour au pays de ces
combattants fait peur à de nombreux
canadiens
bon ok canadiens soient rassurés 0
canadiens ces gens leur reviennent et on
les emprisonne pour 10 15 20 ans donc
les gens vont voir que la justice a fait
son travail que la sécurité publique est
garanti
[Musique]
pour les conservateurs ces djihadistes
ne devrait rentrer au pays que si on a
les preuves nécessaires pour les accusés
je pensais qu'elle était criminel a le
droit de revenir au canada et vivre
librement
on ne sait pas qu ils sont où il s'en
est quelles sont leurs plats
dans les faits très peu de ces jeunes
déjà revenu de la syrie ont été
judiciariser jusqu'à maintenant on a
cette difficulté de connecter cette
trêve lac parce qu'elle est à
l'extérieur du canada dans des zones de
conflit difficilement accessible en
attendant la fin des enquêtes et s'il ya
lieu le dépôt d'accusations certains
jihadistes sont surveillés quand ils
reviennent au pays mais pas tous vous
avez parlé de la surveillance oui ça va
être un outil aussi qu'on voie
privilégiée dans un dossier pas dans
d'autres
c'est dépendamment du risque que la
personne va poser à la sécurité publique
et à la sûreté nationale
mais c'est ce que je peux vous rassurer
c'est chaque cas est pris en charge la
prise en charge psychosociale est
crucial pour réduire le danger que ces
jeunes peuvent représenter qu'on peut
rester suite à des expériences de guerre
ou trauma avec des cicatrices profondes
les services de santé sont déjà à
l'oeuvre pour tenter de les réhabiliter
les réinsérer dans leur famille à
l'école au travail notre porte d'entrée
c'est la souffrance c'est de leur offrir
quelque chose qui leur permettent la
regarder d'une autre façon que par celle
de leur idéologie
je pense que l'édifice et de paul et
déshumanisée de par l'acte partir là-bas
ya quelque chose de très de très humain
je pense dans leur souffrance
on pense que tous ceux qui sont partis
sont partis pour faire la guerre mis en
a plein je pense qu'au québec il y en a
plusieurs qui sont partis pour des
causes humanitaires ne sachant pas
vraiment dans quoi ils s'embarquent et
ces jeunes là bien sûr on peut beaucoup
les aider et surtout l'airé impliqué
dans quelque chose qui a un sens pour
eux dans leur vie si des gens doivent
être arrêtés pour ce qu'ils ont fait
légalement ils le seront mais on doit
prendre en charge des individus mais il
ya des familles peut-être il ya des
enfants
il ya donc il faut s'occuper aussi
cliniquement parlant de tous ces gens là
donc on va revenir avec des enfants des
petits enfants il faut il faut
absolument s'en occuper et les aider à
s'en sortir
mais d entrevue récente de femmes ayant
fui l'état islamique sème le doute
des terroristes islamistes peuvent-ils
être des radicaliser cette britannique
qui avait 15 ans quand elle est arrivée
en syrie vient d'accoucher de son
troisième enfant
les deux premiers sont morts faute de
soins
[Musique]
d'abord les personnes en angleterre ont
été extrêmement choqués parce que l
n'exprimait pas de regret selon la
pédopsychiatre montréalaise les propos
de chamina bi gomme et sa froideur
révèle un choc traumatique
pour survivre elle se dit ceci
mentalement des horreurs qu'elle a vu en
voyant ces images là ce que je voyais
c'est une énorme fragilité et une
dissociation donc une jeune femme qui
est gelée qui ai dis je je ne peux pas
vraiment pensé que mes enfants sont
morts je ne peux pas vraiment pensé que
je me sois mis dans cette situation-là
pour le médecin et son équipe il faut
absolument ramener ces femmes et leurs
enfants pour les soigner les sauver pour
donner les petits-enfants et chance à la
vie christiane boudreau et les parents
de son groupe réclame le rapatriement
immédiat de ces enfants nés en syrie
mais ils craignent que les élections
fédérales retardent leur retour quand ça
se passe pour des élections on veut des
votes
elle alla public est 10e avec les petits
enfants on les veut pas lévy bhl et
petits-enfants savons rien c'est les
votes qui compte
[Musique]